[Musique]
si vous n'avez jamais locaux vides c'est
que vous n'avez pas d'amis c'est
l'étrange conclusion donnée par un
médecin coréens alors que la corée du
sud vient pic de contamination
historique n'avait qu'un nombre record
de contamination 400 milles par jour
beau père médecin new président de la
cour and ice in society a publié un
message sur facebook qui a créé une
grosse polémique les adultes qui n'ont
pas encore une copie 19 sont ceux qui
ont des problèmes relationnels
physiquement chez une femme ce que
j'aime c'est
des cons squat rhino
[Musique]
ça
j'adore la pour l'instant notre vie de
couple nocturne et une par une vraie
parenthèse qui va être fait
ça tombe assez compliqué là
[Musique]
tu me manques la nuit some time la nuit
du riz c'est pour ça que je tombe
amoureux à la base que pour la nuit moi
regarde deux enfants deux ans s'est fait
un moment que je suis célibataire et
comme je suis quelqu'un de spirituel
j'ai fait ma demande à l'univers
envoyez moi l'amour s'il vous plaît
après cette demande à l'univers
stéphane m'a contactée sur les réseaux
sociaux pour moi c'est l'univers qui
m'envoyaient des fans tout bien cet
accent sébastien réseau vient de
belgique et même en belgique on me
demande d'où mon accent reviendra
quelle région belgique côté dinan 1 pour
près de la frontière française
c'est vrai on sait pas trop si c'est un
accent en suisse un accent belge dont on
oublie souvent québécois québécois
avouent tout seul vous fait voyager en
tout cas il me fait le reggae pur
premier rendez vous c'est vraiment
particulier
[Musique]
je me sent submergé par pas mal
d'émotion parce qu'elle a passé un cap
supplémentaire dans tout ce qui est les
auteurs y semer autres un peu trop pour
moi je me sens un peu paumé j'irai
parmi les innombrables filtre du moment
celui ci où l'utilisateur se
démultiplient connaît son heure de
gloire grâce à cette jeune femme enfin
surtout grâce à sa grande aide
voulant suivre le mouvement sur l'écran
du téléphone elle a perdu pied
ah non mais ça va
pas là
[Musique]
la meilleure give up croyait toujours en
vos rêves les enfants on va prendre le
temps après on va prendre le temps oui
faut qu'on se connaît tous un peu plus à
tous niveaux un bon allez on va au lit
maintenant aller dans la chambre allait
bien mais qu'on
m'ont battu on va vous placez un peu
avant le déjeuner si ça ne vous ennuie
pas puisque on ne va pas se mentir chez
mathieu il y à un revêtement c'est du ca
ca 1 on est bien d'accord charlotte ah
oui c'est ducasse et voilà moi j'ai 10
du ca sympa pour vous disiez que j'avais
envie de vous avez dit si ça vous fait
du bien tant mieux